now I also agree i think as our bus said
the whole class agrees that injecting
values into the globalized system since
we're fast approaching a time when
competition for resources is going to
make it dangerous is a good idea but if
we were to think of this class as a
workshop to come up with a list of
actions as to how we would implement
this i don't think i would be very
productive because i've been thinking
about ways to implement this the
injection of values into the system and
the closest i think one of the readings
gets to it is the one by johnston about
a bad politic and he brings the idea of
a faith-based diplomat or religious
attache and if we were to have this idea
on the table and see if it was a way of
implementing this injection do you think
it's applicable or can it be seen as an
infringement even upon serenity because
you're bypassing political measures in
appealing on a personal level by
appointing someone religious who will
have a predominantly political mission
in my leave and if this is if you think
this is not applicable or not a good way
then what how can we actually implement
your vision yeah I don't think it is a
particularly good way I'm out i think
you're going to get very far by
appointing boosters why i thought it was
a bit of a strange idea to have a sort
of religious attache said okay yeah
wasn't fully persuasive no it would
certainly give you know cuz ya you used
to dealing at embassies with very
strange name d'etat Shay's that usually
turn out to have a technol technological
expertise that's got very little to do
with you know I mean that would be that
would be a good one actually I that
would definitely be one role for the
religious attetion confuse the enemy
no I think I think you see how you bring
this the this in is you you talk about
the values and I say this you know I
always emphasize this it doesn't have to
come through religious faith but it's
just that the values that are associated
with religious faith that is best our
values that lend themselves to for
example tackling global poverty in
Africa climate change isolating
extremists and terrorists and actually I
would argue even to making your economic
system work better so I would say that
you you the way of doing this is not
actually to try and you know rerun these
debates through the prism of religious
doctrine but on the contrary to say
actually the only way that we are going
to make the world work and solve these
problems is through these strong values
guiding the process of resolution of
these challenges you see what I mean I
do but on a tangible we like who do we
address and how do we go about doing it
and like globalization has many aspects
from global investment management let's
say to enter internet like relations
between certain nations so there's a
political aspect as an economic aspect
or their social relations how like won't
provided that we agree on the values and
I do i do agree with you when you say
that there are universal values coming
from within the fates that we can use
for this to this end how do we do this
on a policy basis how do we make this an
agenda for ourselves well we make an
agenda for ourselves for example me just
to take the issue to do with climate
change we've got a major problem to do
with climate change and the problem is
very very simple China and India
going to industrialize hundreds of
millions of their people and it will
engage in industrialization about four
or five times the equivalent of that of
the United States of America and about
five times the speed so and they're
going to do it right but they want to do
it responsibly they prefer to do it
responsibly and sustainably but they've
got to lift their people out of poverty
for the west and its really worried that
if if what we do is we take a whole lot
of action on climate change supposing we
start to change our economies you know
supposing we we we tack certain and
environmental Bad's in order to
discourage the behavior we are we
worried we're going to end up being
uncompetitive with these countries as
they industrialize so they're going to
get a free rider on our back right now
you cannot resolve this issue in my view
unless you start from a basic principle
that this is a global community problem
and it cannot be resolved on the basis
of interest narrowly defined but rather
has to be resolved on the basis of
equity which means for example we share
technology that we develop we partner we
encourage we make sure that for example
with deforestation and large parts of
the world that are being deforested when
this is a major part of the climate
change problem we have to intervene we
have to be prepared to fund the
intervention this is going to be
necessary right now none of this can be
done in my view without the concept of
equity in it so what I would say is that
you know faith-based politics at its
best says we import these values to the
solution of this problem now you're
still going to work out what's your best
cap-and-trade system the technical
details of how the Clean Development
Mechanism were
how technology transfer can be
associated with intellectual property
rights all of that has to be done you
know don't misunderstand me has to be
then you know there's no point in hiring
the vicar in takana guides on it come
back you know if you take for example
the the as I know you studied before the
Jubilee 2000 campaign you know this was
a mobilization of faith for a purpose in
my view it steadily in time to come
people will look back at that moment
because actually I think there have been
some very interesting changes in Africa
that arose out of that as a moment at
which the world got into a different
relationship with Africa so is it me
yeah that's clarified to me thank you